let's talk about why this stuff's
happening because someone actually
chatted us we've talked about esg before
it's environmental social and governance
rating someone mentioned that as we're
talking about these this twix commercial
and this doritos commercial that the
reason they're doing this is because
they're trying to reduce their risk as
they appear to creditors i don't believe
that
um
esg ratings are legit
they're uh
so let me just read it says um
esg rating measures a company's exposure
to long-term environmental social and
governance risks these risks involving
issues such as energy efficiency worker
safety and board independence have
financial implications but they are
often not highlighted during traditional
financial reviews investors who use esg
ratings to supplement financial analysis
can gain a broader view of a company's
long-term potential
so
there are companies that issue an esg
score yeah they're woke
right a lot of them like most companies
are and so if you're not woke they'll
say you have a very high risk because oh
what's that california says you got to
have a woman and a person of color on
your board and you don't high risk of
government intervention
bad score right so what do they do
this other story that was breaking is
that a white male who was fired from a
north carolina hospital
sued for 10 million dollars because they
replaced them with a black woman and
apparently they fired a bunch of white
male executives and hired that hired you
know black people to replace them and
they were and the jury was like you
can't just fire people for being white
and apparently this dude was on uh was
sitting in board meetings discussing
diversity and like how to help the
hospital and they fired him
so what's happening is for a lot of
companies in order to improve their esg
they're doing all the the green stuff
green initiatives and they're doing all
the woke stuff
they want to have reduced risk but i
actually think this will backfire for
one doritos with that commercial about
the ghost who turned out to be gay and
the derry and the twix thing which has
nothing to do with cookies but it's like
a boy who has a dress
that's high risk
like if i was an investor
and i was like
well i have invested in companies i'll
tell you this i've invested in several
companies if they come to me and and i
say what's your strategy for like
growing the business and they go
well we're a company that manufactures
you know uh we we
refine steel and in these times steel is
very expensive i'll say wonderful
wonderful well people need steel okay so
what's your plan for marketing they go
gender yes we're going to make
commercials about people choosing
you're going to spend money say what
that could be a dividend
or could hire more people
to sell an ideology having nothing to do
with steel or could increase steel
production or could increase steel
production but but i i think there's two
things one some people are worried about
their scores this is basically social
social credit for corporations yeah but
some people just are buying this this is
this is religion now this is the
religion i mean there was a time that's
their tithe
well no this is this is their their
their preaching there was there was a
time when this country was
overwhelmingly christian and people
would companies would be like i am not
going to offend the sensibilities by
putting a pentagram on something right
magic the gathering has a card called
unholy strength it requires swamp energy
or black mana as it's called is that is
that pretty sure and the character on
the card is like a guy leaning back with
a burning pentagram behind him in the
early 90s a bunch of religious groups
said hey this is offensive you can't do
that so they removed the art from
subsequent versions because there was a
time when that christianity had some
swing even tipper gore who was
vice president al gore's wife democrat
democrat who forced there to be explicit
warnings labels
on records that she thought were uh you
know offensive to her sensibilities as
we lose our judeo-christian moral
framework and it is supplanted by lack
thereof
you get
chaos exactly it is it is turning into
that yeah i mean like that's something
that's happening at post-millennial even
we're being targeted by i think we
talked about it before we targeted by
like these activists
who have no moral standing in anything
at all just say a whole bunch of lies
about us advertisers believe them
without looking into it at all
um it's funny because we're getting some
of that too are you getting it too yeah
i know that daily wire is getting it too
and revolver it doesn't all of them
we're working toward moving into a
position where that's going to have zero
impact we're getting close yeah it's
just the crazy thing is that um we've
had some issues some issues where these
woke activists have contacted our
advertisers
and the advertisers then like have like
an internal meeting and they're like we
don't understand how temple is
controversial and so
yeah i've had like conversations where
they're like they were actually really
worried at first and then they looked at
the site and then did a did research
into into you and they were confused as
to what the activists were claiming and
i was like so what's the conclusion they
were like they made a mistake
nice wow yeah well you have people who
are actually looking into it a lot of
advertisers a lot of companies they
don't even think about it they just say
okay we're out well yeah we're good it's
sad sorry it's very
satisfying well it's because they're
they're not incentivized to right
because even if what the person is
saying about you is a total lie and even
if the advertiser knows a total lie if
they still think it's going to hurt
their bottom line to work with you
they're going to cut you loose right
or if they just don't care enough to
figure it out yeah
i think companies some companies are
starting to get wise to the fact that
it could be really bad for their
business so there was or was it surf
shark yeah yeah
um uh so i'll say two things for one one
of the sponsors of the show is a vpn
company virtual shield we shot them all
the time right but uh that's just full
disclosure because this has nothing to
do with them i'm only saying that
because i don't want this to be viewed
as a conflict of interest but surf shark
is a vpn and they sold out you guys
right
they sure did they canceled on you
because one guy tweeted like andy no was
a bad person right yeah and andy noah is
a crime reporter and this person commits
crimes
here's what needs to happen
don't buy doritos
we won't yeah we won't and i want
doritos no i wasn't okay anyway but twix
is off the menu and who and who owns
twix mars is it mars i don't know what
else do they make
everything stop buying from these
companies
and surf shark
cancel your subscription to them
because the left does
yeah and conservatives for too long have
just gone along with this being like
well whatever i do my own thing i'll
i'll consume whatever products i want
and there hasn't been a lot of activism
on that side or even just on the side of
people who want to uphold things like
constitutional rights you know they're
not going around telling everyone what
to do and how to live their lives but
you can act with your own you know your
own pocketbook i got an idea
here's the activism that we need it's
not about a conservative it's not about
being independent it's not about being
libertarian
here's here's the activism the right
really needs
stop eating sugar yes no no no no i'm
not saying all sugar do keto i'm saying
cut out the cookies yes no more no more
garbage no more garbage no junk food you
should be when you go to the store i
tell you this man meat is expensive
but you you you got to understand how
much you're wasting on these sugary
coffee drinks from starbucks
don't go to starbucks anymore why what
do they have to offer you a bottle of
water okay fine
fine we've replaced all of our plastic
bottles with glass bottles that we put
our own filtered water in now because
i'm like it's time to put up or shut up
i'm eating better i'm cutting out the
donuts the sugary garbage the candy the
all that crap
imagine this that photo that jackpot
posted of all of these people walking
around just in shape why because food
was real yes imagine that the left can
be sickly body positive or whatever you
want to call it
unwell
suffering in their minds
and the one thing that you can do
get in shape start exercising cut out
the candy cut out the doritos cut out
the starbucks these are companies that
are selling you out and using your money
to promote ridiculous ideologies that
don't even sell their product so don't
support them
this is what i'm saying right it makes a
lot of sense i would not eat a dorito
right now
if you were to pay me for it why because
i'm on a diet and it doesn't mean i'm on
a diet to lose weight it means i'm on a
specific regimen of the food that i eat
for a specific reason yeah of course
fresh vegetables
fresh fruits
meats
i'm not eating the garbage processed
crap anymore yeah well yeah i don't have
it in my house like yeah i don't buy
that stuff for my kid i just don't want
it i mean you know when like we have
sweets i am i'm certainly never going to
give up sweets but i make cookies i make
cookies at home make it yourself yeah i
made banana bread muffins this week and
we were very excited it's funny because
conservatives won't really mobilize in
that way often i'm hoping that changes
i'm hoping we can convince people not to
purchase these products because that's
what needs to happen i just find it
hilarious that
i mean
the radical left
you know spent like i said you spent a
summer burning down cities people died
this is a very energetic and mobilized
group of people to put it kindly and
for all these cries you hear on the left
about conservatives are so dangerous and
they're going to ride and kill people
like we can't even get conservatives to
stop eating twix bars like i don't think
this is what i'm saying but they're that
much of a threat unfortunately and it's
this is really really simple yeah you
don't need to remember a list of
companies not to buy from yeah you don't
need to go to the store and go oh pepsi
are we boycotting pepsi all you need to
do is say i eat farm fresh meats
cheeses
and veggies yeah done and
then when you go to the store and you're
like which candy bar was i boycotting
all of them
they poison your mind they're bad for
you yeah well and also i just want to
i'm on board with that i just want to
clarify what i'm saying like not a
threat i'm saying conservatives do need
to be a threat in the sense that
corporations need to understand that we
are a large consumer block and their
business can suffer if they upset us if
they walk all over us if they try to
insult us i'm just thinking about
organization 100 but but not if not if
the approach is is you focus on yourself
no i mean yes i mean to i mean to
boycott some of the com like some of the
companies that's true are taking these
behaviors not just the food companies i
mean it's easy it's easy to say i'm not
gonna buy chips you know i mean
there's a lot of that kind of stuff i
was never buying anyway like i was never
gonna be
i was never the target audience for the
doritos ad because i've literally never
bought a doritos it's time to start uh
look daily wire is doing it and we're
definitely doing it they're way bigger
than we are but producing culture i
think that's so important we need to get
to the point where it's like no no don't
don't don't watch disney watch you know
daily wire's new show watch tim cast but
that's his cast
yeah no more disney dude we've got some
stuff we could produce you know what i
mean we got we got two shows so far we
have four four total shows on the t on
timecast.com nice
the fifth show is in production right
now where we're doing trials and
auditions and like test runs for a pop
culture show there's a lot of pop
culture stuff to talk
about i mean we're doing uh we're doing
a lot of great podcasts at post
millennials we have this one cancel this
dinesh d'souza was just on oh
but
here's where we have we actually i think
we apparently have um ari hoffman doing
an interview with uh donald trump
tomorrow certainly oh wow that is that
is good and it's on our rumble channel
this is more political content right
political connection and podcasts are
still very much right wing conservative
whatever like talk radio right that's
why we're do we do the cast castle vlog
every day we have an animator who makes
silly jokes like the the the shirt we
just sold yes
step on snack and find out go to
timcast.com
do actually do i still have it yeah here
check it out
step on snack and find out this this
amazing t-shirt you can get by going to
timcast.com and clicking store and then
scroll down it's on the bottom we got to
rearrange it better but this will soon
be up on the youtube as well this is
from one of the vlog episodes we made
where kent who's the animator had a
t-shirt that luke was wearing and said
step on snack and find out something he
made up and so we were like let's make
that shirt it's just silly and funny
look at that angry cute little snake so
cute all angry about it and it's just a
silly gig it's meant to be silly like
you know step on snack and so that's the
the vlog is something conservatives
don't do
what does the daily wire have podcast
podcast podcast podcast podcast but now
they have the movies now they're doing a
movie a movie yeah and they're doing
more
sitcoms you have to start you have to
start somewhere so i'm i'm actually in
that i'm actually i've been told brandon
is that that song being on the top of
the charts
about comedy specials oh great we want a
tim cast exclusive comedy special we won
did you see that jim brewer one did you
say i i saw a clip of it i don't know
when it was from but basically somebody
sneezed in the audience and he jokingly
like set off an alarm like no
we also speaking of culture there's this
really awesome channel that makes
animated political cartoons oh really
which i think is a great thing to be
doing right now it's called freedom
tunes if you guys just want to check but
sheamus
as i have told you
you need a pop culture version of that
i've been yeah no i want to do that
we've been i've been well i don't want
to why are we doing much away yeah we
will i i don't want to give too much
away at 100 percent i want to give
someone like you and i should talk about
it after the show got some ideas yeah
but we also there's another show i'm
surprised you didn't mention the sixth
show tim cast is launching love dr
sheamus that's right we had a whole
conversation about this love doctor
his advice
here's the pitch
here's here's the pitch it's sheamus he
takes calls
every single time someone calls asking
for advice he advised them to go to
church go to church or or if i mean
anytime i have a couple of prayers i'm
thinking like any time anyone calls me
with any kind of problem with the
relationship i'll be like just break up
this is the headache for can you worry
about it can you save the relationship
yes go to church all right you go to
church go to church what you guys need
to do is go to church there you go now
we love dr sheamus i mean look i think
it's got staying power i think people
would love to watch something like that
what if we did like a full a full series
like a 13 episode arc of an animated
show i would love to do that you kidding
me i'd love to do that i've got like
ideas up the wazoo for an animated
series yeah 100 let's do 20 minute
episodes yeah let's do it you guys heard
it here tim committed that's right are
you joking
insults me because here's the thing
tim's nice to be on camera right but
behind the scenes he's constantly
insulting me throwing things at me even
and i don't mean ideas he's like the
bully shame no he's doing it with the
witch's hat yeah exactly
the other day i told tim him and his
nanny looked weird and he went right
yeah and there you were in your princess
dress yeah exactly
feel good
yeah thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to watch live you can check
out this channel monday through friday
at 8 00 pm and don't forget to smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel and if you want more unfiltered
and uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time